hello
everyone uh I'm very excited to
introduce Anna she's a very experienced
uh dat analyst and um have a lot of
experience payments industry so thank
you let's
start thanks thanks for the introduction
uh so my name is Anna chosa and today I
would like to talk to you about uh
different ways to do future encoding so
first of all a little bit about me so
I'm Anna I'm uh I work as a data
scientist in um payments company called
mly uh mly is a Dutch company based in
Amsterdam and it's a payment service
provider meaning that uh we offer a
payment platform through which web shops
are able to process their payments as a
data scientist I work in the customer
monitoring team which means that I my
work revolves around building models for
Automation and optimiz optimizing of uh
processes that are in the monitoring
domain
so what I'm going to talk about today is
categorical data and shortly what is
categorical data there are many
different data types right but
categorical data is anything that you
can think of in terms of groups for
example um names places gender job
titles all of these are types of
categorical data and what we see in
everyday life especially in the data
science world is that we see this kind
of data as um good source of uh
information for building models however
with some exceptions most of the models
can't accept categorical data such they
need to be the categorical data needs to
be transformed in certain way for the
models to be able to understand it and
that is it has to be trans transformed
into numeric into numerical type now the
process of transforming this categorical
data into numerical data is called
feature encoding and that's what I'm
talking about
today a little bit about the data that I
see in my daily life so like I said I
work on uh in payments um what it means
what that means for the data that the uh
basic data type is U payments now
payments when you hear payments it might
sound immediately that it's mostly
numerical data and for sure volume which
is a very important characteristic of a
payment is numerical but there are
actually many more data points around
the payment that are from the
categorical de think of payment methods
something like credit card ideal Clara
these are all categorical values or the
status of payment whether it's paid
canel and so on the IP address this is a
tricky one it looks like numbers but
it's actually a category behind it the
numbers don't uh don't convey a meaning
country where the payment is processed
and actually many others so as we see um
there are many types of categorical data
that are revolving in the payment
industry and so I believe in many other
Industries and this is actually the
motivation behind my talk I work with
this kind of data and I explore
different ways of future en coding and
my learnings I would like to share with
you
today so what was my challenge I was
working on a regulatory model um and I
had to uh use country as a data point so
these country names they look something
like this so we see there are 195 95
countries all the all the countries in
the world and they were not very
straightforward to uh trans transform
into numericals I'll show later uh why
and I'll show later also how I fixed it
but before we go on into that let's see
how many of the people here ever use
categorical data during model
development let's show by a raise of
hands okay that's quite a bit and how
many of you then ever experienced a
challenge into encoding and into
numerical right okay well I'm happy to
see that because uh then I hope the
content of this talk will will help uh
resolve at least some of these
challenges so now i' would like to I
would like you to think of this
challenge that you faced in your daily
work um so when you had when you face
the challenge of encoding a categorical
variable and I would like you to keep it
in your mind during the uh during this
presentation because what I'll do is
I'll present different ways of encoding
and uh hopefully some of these ways
could be applicable to your
case then when you go back to work on
Monday you could maybe think about
applying it to your uh use case and
seeing whether your model perform is
better with this new way of encoding the
data so if you don't have such an
example it's also fine to use my example
but if you have something applicable to
you it could be also nice and um Al yeah
more uh more
applicable so what's the plan for today
shortly I'm going to show three groups
of encoders starting from simpler ones
uh all the way to more advanced for each
of them I will show uh when it's good to
use them when it is not good to use them
and also what if you decide to use them
what to pay attention to in the end I'll
provide a QR code with a summary of
everything that I say so that will
include all the definitions all the
theory also the examples so you'll be
able to scan it and take it home with
you and a bonus there is there also
there will be content on the python
built-in methods that where you can find
all of these encoders that I'll present
about today so everything I show today
will is easily um integratable with
second L pipelines and um it's based
actually on a couple of libraries that
you can find in the in the summary as
well so the goal for today simply we
will learn about different encoding
methods and by the end of the
presentation I hope you will uh learn
new ways and you will learn how to
choose exactly the one that you need
that will help your models perform
better so the buil-in methods I was I
was mentioning um so everything that I
showed today will be at least at one or
sometimes in two of this Library pyed
learn future engine and category
encoders most of the most of the time
it's a single line of code that you need
to add to your uh yeah to your script
and it is easily integratable with the
rest of the pipeline which is pretty
nice so it's mostly about like
integrating it is not so hard as
choosing what exactly want to use and
that's what we're focusing on
today so then let's start the first part
basic encoders also more commonly known
let's start with something called
ordinal encoder so this is a simple one
it just Maps every category to a
distinct numerical
value as the name suggests it's good to
use with ordinal data and ordinal data
is everything that if you put the values
in order it makes sense it tells the
story let's see an example if we have
educational levels Bachelor Masters and
PhD this order makes sense it tells
something about the data that you're
that that you're dealing with so what we
would do here with the ordinal encoder
is we map each value to a c uh to one
numerical value and then we replace the
data
accordingly as simple as that you can
use this also if you're dealing with um
maybe customer rating subscription types
basic Advanced premium these kind of
things that so they are all data points
that have an order when it's not good to
use it when data is not ordinal let's
take an example of eye color so we have
four different eye colors uh and if we
encode them with uh with ordinal coder
what we end up with is something like
this which is yeah the model will accept
it and will work with it but it also
think that blue is twice as much of
brown of something which yeah in reality
doesn't really tell any context so in
this case when we are not dealing with
orinal data better to go with another
approach one of the ones that we see
later second encoder is frequency
encoder it's actually similar to the
label encoder but here instead of
mapping to a a numerical value we map to
a specific count that we see of that
value Val in the training set it's nice
when you have high cardinality because
this decreases the cardinality of your
data and makes it simpler for the model
to find patterns and it conveys some
information about your data point as
well so for example in terms of if we
have a data set with sold products here
we have chair table and plate as an
example chair we see three times table
we see two times plate we see one time
so when we repl it in data it looks like
this say we're working on a net revenue
model the model will know that chair is
the most popular sold um product table
is second plate is third and in reality
we have many more products like I said
with high cardinality so this can be
quite useful however there is a downside
to this is um if all of or most of your
values end up in equal number of
observations something like this if we
have three chairs and three tables we
encode data would look like this so if
we see um yeah it's a any variable with
a single unique value means nothing to a
model it won't be informative so chances
are later on in some future encoding uh
in some future selection step this will
be dropped anyways so you might as well
save yourself the yeah the work around
this and go with the different encoder
instead if you notice this kind of
behavior in your
data last one of the simple encoders a
wellknown one hot encoder so here we
create binary features per
category nice to use when you have low
cardinality because then we make sure
that the data doesn't become too big and
sparse eye color is a perfect example
for this we have four different colors
we encod them so basically every column
here shows where the row belongs like
the first row has the one in the uh in
the column called Brown which means that
the this person has brown eyes and so on
so this is quite handy and can be
understood well by the model what you
can do here it's nice skip the last
column you avoid multi multicolinearity
especially a problem in linear models
and why you can do this is because uh
then we don't have black anymore as a as
a column sure but black is still encoded
it's encoded with three zeros and if you
read this it just means that it's not
brown it's not bre and it's not green so
it must be black right because there are
only so many eye
colors where you have to be careful it's
if you're working with products for
example here product there can be
different right so if we decide to drop
plate as a as a column that's fine but
if new products come along like desk
they will have the same encoding as the
one they with dropped and sem en coding
means information loss and now it
doesn't mean that you can never use this
but it means that it's good to check
with the business whether this is an
information loss that is not that would
make the model the the model not
applicable anymore so this is something
to pay attention to and uh if it's a
problem then it's better to go with all
of the
cles so one more thing when it's not
good to use it with high cardinality so
the opposite case is if we have for
example day of years day of the year
there are 365 days of the year and we if
we create a binary column for each of
them we end up with something like this
which yeah is very big and sparse data
and will probably just confuse any model
that we injest this into so for this
kind of data we'll see other techniques
later that it's better that would be
more
applicable so that concludes the first
part the simple encoders um and we move
on to the next part which are also
relatively simple but they are powerful
uh because they uh especially because
they can be used as a helper encoders to
other encoders so we can use this in
combination with others with ones
already presented and some others from
late so let's see first one is called
rare label
encoder and what it does is it groups in
frequent categories into one rare
category it works well when again when
you have c c cardinality and because it
decreases the cardinality and another
reason is here high cardinality should
be accompanied by under represented
categories let's see how that looks in
an example if we have uh if we have data
about payment methods so here we have
values like ideal Clara credit card
right and they appear quite a bit in the
data set we can we can see it in
multiple rows but then we see EPS so
forth vales and they are only
represented by a single row and this is
not enough data for a model to be able
to learn from to find patterns probably
it will yeah overgeneralize on this uh
actually become overly specific on these
categories and will over fit them them
so what is better to do here is we apply
the rare label encoder which means that
all of these values that are under
represented will just end up belonging
to a single rare label class and this R
Lael class will if you read it it will
mean something like yeah we have ideal
clarina credit card and then all others
this is very nice to use and but
important important to note here like I
said it's a helper encoder so you still
have to apply another encoder next to it
because here we still don't have
numerical data so after this you can
choose another method that is um yeah in
accordance with the definitions and um
and uh yeah continue
encoding be careful to not use the r
label encoder even if you have
underrepresented values if those R
values are
meaningful so let's see an example like
let's keep to the same example right
with the payment methods let's say we we
encoded this with rare label it's fine
and then in production we see something
like Apple pay right so this is
something that we've never seen on
training Data before and the rare label
encoder what it will do it will just
automatically bucket it as a rare label
because if it's only seen one one of
them what's the problem here is that
maybe this is a new product and by
bucketing it bucketing it with all the
products that that didn't perform so
well in the past maybe we're not giving
it a chance in our predictions so this
is another scenario where it's good to
check with the business and the
stakeholders that this is not leading to
Too Much Information loss and we're not
blindly allocating to the R
Class hash
encoder hash encoder is about applying a
hash function to create hash buckets so
again we're bucketing it but in a
different way why it's different
we'll see now so um first of all when
it's good to use is when we have very
high cardinality has encoder is quite
nice when you have to be Memory
efficient um and when we want to reduce
the D dimensionality of the data a good
example for this is author names because
auo uh this um this feature is U by
itself is something that initially
contains a lot of authors there are a
lot of authors in the world and chances
are when you go to production you will
have many more as well so what the hash
encoder does is you choose the hash
function and then you um apply to each
of them and uh they get encoded into
single buckets so in this case J and
Mark twin ended up in bucket number zero
Jak rolling canag got chrisy in bucket
number one and George Orwell in bucket
number two to bit more specific about
how this works is that we apply a hash
function and then in order to make sure
that we have as many categories as we
expect we apply a modules on top so for
example a mod of um three in this case
it will always give a remainer of uh
zero one or two and that's why you end
up with three groups so it's important
to apply that um that that that last
step of the in the hash function so when
you specify how many buckets you want to
see that's the mod that will be applied
to the hash function and that's how then
it's uh decided where Each of which
bucket each of the values will will
belong to now this one um why it's nice
is first of all it reduces
dimensionality but also it can work on
the Fly you don't have to store anything
in memory you don't have to store this
mapping because the hash function can be
just applied on new values and the third
reason why it's nice is because when you
have new unseen values in your data in
production let's say a new uh someone
new in the world wrote a book you can
directly hash it and create a allocate
it to a bucket without having to go back
to your pre-processing and encoding
again so this makes a difference from
the previous
encoders so yeah that's how our data
looks like from five different values
here we ended up with three but in
reality this would be like from yeah
thousands and thousands to to a smaller
number it's not nice to use it on
original data because then um yeah if we
apply it on let's say we have this
example with subscriptions we can apply
it but in this case if you see basic and
premium end up in the same bucket and
this leads to some important information
losss because here we have meaningful
information in the ordering of our
variables so here the label encoder
would make more
sense so the order relationship between
the subscriptions we lose it here so we
that's why we don't want to do
it so that concludes part two and I'm
moving on to the last part it's the
about the advanced encoders and what
makes them different from everything
that we saw before is that this encoders
don't only take into account the feature
itself they also take into account the
target so they pull ination
from the target variable as well to make
something meaningful for the model to
learn from and let's see how that's
possible the first one is the mean or
Target encoder and the name comes from
the definition that we C for each class
of categorical variable we calculate the
mean of the target for that
class it's nice with high cardinality
again and nice to use when you have
regression or binal classification with
multi classific ification there is
something we have to be careful with
I'll show that in a bit as well let's
first see the binary classification have
the payment methods here um and whether
the payment was fraudulent or not so
let's imagine this is a payments data
set where we see whether a payment was
fraud or not and we see its payment
method so for ideal how would we encode
it so we take the class ideal and then
we calculate the mean of the values
under the target so here we have one
zero and another zero so the mean of two
zeros is just a zero so we'll encode
ideal with a zero then we have Clara
which has one one and a zero the a their
average is 0.5 so that will be our
encoding similarly for credit card we
end up with
0.66 and that's how we turn our data
into something uh meaningful that tells
basically tells how often in the past
this payment method has been associated
with fraud and then when we have an
incoming payment in production the model
knows that that okay maybe credit card
is actually the most Su susceptible to
fraud we should be more careful with
creating a
prediction something to be careful here
and um it could be argued that we this
leads to some sort of data leakage why
because um basically here we are taking
into when we're uh calculating the value
for a single payment we also take into
account the target value of that single
payment and in production when we have
an an incoming penguin we don't yet know
it's Target so it doesn't fully mimic
how it would look in production and the
way to solve that is by something called
leave on leave one out approach so
basically if we say let's say for the
first row of credit card we will encode
it by only taking into a count the
second the second and the third one and
then instead of 66 we end up with a with
a value 0. five so this is an approach
if you want to be extra secure there is
no data
leakage another thing to be careful what
I mentioned earlier with multi multic
class classification is we have if we
have more than two features in the I
mean more than two classes in the Target
here we have uh status of payment paid
cancel and the client and let's say we
want to predict it um what we see here
is the target is categorical and we can
take mean in categorical data so what we
what what we can do instead is we can
first apply one hold en coding that we
covered earlier now we apply it on the
Target and then for each of the
resulting columns we can apply the
target uh we can apply the target
encoder on top of them and that way we
will encode we will uh encode for each
of the different uh values in the Target
variable um and we avoid the challenge
of multic
classification when not to use it is
when we have dependencies between
categorical features or the future
Target relationship changes over time so
for example in this case we see that
credit card in country a always led to
fraud and credit card in country B
always led to nonf fraud let's say in
simple terms now if we applied the
Target and CER as we did before our data
would look something like this right we
had 66 before but uh still 66 and a
leads to um fraud 66 and B leads to non
fraud so we actually then expect the
model to figure out this combination and
um yeah U learn it into uh to tun it uh
to find the parameters but we have done
an expectation of the models to figure
this out although we already found this
relationship between payment method and
Country as features and in this case
what could be nice is what take take one
step back into feature engineering and
think about how we can create one
feature that could combine payment
method and Country together because we
know they are related and this could be
as simple as concatenating the two for
example
and then only then we apply the target
encoding on top so that could be the the
the
workr the next one I'll cover is the
weight of evidence encoder so this one
is uh is similar to Target encoding
takes information from the target but
only with a different formula instead of
the mean it looks the ratio between
goods and Bets what goods and Bets means
here is Goods is everything that has a
target of zero B is everything that has
a target of one the reason for it is
that um um yeah the reason for it is
because this comes from uh this encoder
originates in banking and uh there uh
there there was always the need to see
if someone is a bad client or is going
to be uh going into default so here
we're looking at the ratio between the
good and the bad class um and taking the
log in other words this a logot Al more
commonly known um it's nice to apply to
nominal data so not ordinal and nice to
use in logistic progression models
because of that logo
component so for for example in this
case we look at the ratio between so
probability of zero here is we have
three out of four zero so it's 75 of one
is one out of four uh is the one so it's
0 25 and the ratio uh we find the log
and it's uh 74 47 similarly we find it
for credit card now something nice to
notice here is that um yeah the log of
um positive uh that ends up
uh when the logo is positive it
indicates to the model that there were
more Goods than beds and the absolute
value indicates how much more and
similarly with negative so that's how it
conveys the information to the
model and then we can easily apply to
logistic progression because that it
also works with logos not nice to use
with orinal data because then we're
losing quite a bit of meaningful in
interval
information finally the last one is a
cat boot cat boost encoder simple way to
put it is it's a time where Target and
coding basically works the same way as a
Target as Target and coding but instead
of taking into account all of the data
it only takes into account the roles
that happened before a specific role so
it's nice to use it when there is a Time
dependency and there is a future Target
relationship that changes over time
which if you remember was a downside of
Target
encoder if we see the example here let's
say that we want to calculate for credit
card the last role we will take into
account the two ones that happened
before we'll calculate the mean of those
and we'll apply to the last one so
something important to mention here is
that for every row we will have a
different value so for every uh
different value of every different
category will have a different value
which makes this encoder more
computational expensive so before using
it make sure that uh it's feasible in
your setup when it's not nice to use it
when you have limited data so or very
large feature set because of
computation um so for example here we
have too little information on this
medical symptoms leg and arm pain it's
insufficient data so it's better to
apply something like rare label encoder
first and then continue with cat
boost so that's that concludes all the
encoders and before I uh yeah before
before I close the co talk I will
quickly show you how I solve my
challenge that was about representing
countries data in the regulatory
model so basically the challenge looked
like this I had this countries data
table and uh I mean feature and then I
had to build a regulatory model which
because of s mations had to build
logistic progression something had to
happen in between and the first approach
was okay let's want hot and cot but that
ended up like this and that wasn't very
useful for the ristic agression so
instead went to step back look at the
countries what's nice is that um there
can't be more countries While most of
the time appearing in the world so we
can't don't have to uh uh worry about
new values coming in production we noted
some values being under represented so
first applied rare label encoder and
because of the logistic progression
requirements what was most applicable
here was the weight of evidence en
coder one last remark I will make is
that always fit transform on train set
and transform on test on and production
so that will make sure that you don't
introduce data leakage in your
data in your
model so that would look like
that so that that that concludes my talk
here's the QR code that I promised in
the start you can scan it and you will
end up with a uh with a summary of
everything that I said uh when to use
the encoders when not to use them what
to pay attention to their definitions
also including the examples that I gave
and on top also the built-in methods
where you can find them in the um in
Python now you can think back about the
examples that you thought about in the
start and hopefully something of this
was applicable to your case and when you
go back to work on Monday you can try it
on your model and hopefully it helps it
predict better in my case it helped
performance quite well thanks thanks a
lot everyone and I'm all forward to
questions also after this talk you can
approach
me